un ataque brutal con cuchillo y mientras
volvía de su hora de almuerzo era una
empleada administrativa de la policía de
49 años y madre de dos hijos murió como
consecuencia de las heridas
el atacante un supuesto islamista nacido
en túnez falleció después de recibir
disparos de los agentes que se
encontraban a las afueras de la estación
esto ocurrió en camboya un pueblo a 60
km de parís el primer ministro jan
castex no tardó en llegar a la escena
del crimen junto con el ministro del
interior de pan y ajo ha sido mis
primeros pensamientos están con su
familia y sus seres queridos ya tu sé
por el nivel fue una vez más el
departamento de i blind se puso en
guardia en contra del flagelo del
terrorismo
que todos recordamos el terrible ataque
en magnan bill en 2016 y más
recientemente el asesinato de samuel
para ti el fiscal nacional
antiterrorista de francia alguien habló
y confirmó que unos comentarios hechos
por el atacante apuntaban hacia un
motivo terrorista aunque quiet uber se
abrió una investigación por el asesinato
de una persona con un cargo público en
relación
una acción terrorista y con asociación
con conocidos terroristas según una
fuente anónima de la policía del
atacante tenía 36 años y llegó a francia
en 2009 obtuvo su residencia y
recientemente se mudó al hamwi y de
acuerdo con esta fuente era un
desconocido para las fuerzas de
seguridad